economía en france 24 saludo a mi
compañera daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches negociaciones entre
londres y bruselas no hay acuerdos se
empieza a acabar el tiempo que es lo que
está pasando allí
santiago pues nunca sobra recordar cómo
inició esta historia y es que el 31 de
enero de este año el reino unido--
abandonó la unión europea pero quedó
pendiente de definir cómo será la
relación comercial desde 2021 para eso
se dio un periodo de negociación que
vence el 31 de diciembre pero los
avances como usted dice en estos meses
han sido prácticamente nulos y las
partes ya se están alistando para partir
cobijas de manera abrupta el primer
ministro británico boris johnson había
amenazado con levantarse de la mesa si
hoy no había consenso se espera que tome
una decisión este viernes que a su vez
es el segundo día de una reunión de
líderes europeos dos cosas para destacar
de este encuentro la primera que la
presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen tuvo que abandonar
el recinto porque hay positivos por kobe
en su entorno y también hubo protestas
afuera de la sede del organismo
y era alemana angela merkel dijo a
última hora que hay cierto movimiento en
las conversaciones y el presidente de
francia también se refirió al asunto
y voy a ser muy claro aquí y conocemos
los puntos que aún deben discutirse en
los que todavía no hemos encontrado una
solución la pesca en ningún caso
nuestros pescadores serán sacrificados
por el break city por lo tanto preservar
el acceso a las aguas británicas para
nuestros pescadores y hablo por todos
los países de europa interesados
incluida francia es un punto importante
en estas discusiones
seguimos a la expectativa entonces de un
resultado vamos a argentina porque allí
a punta de protestas lograron un aumento
en el salario mínimo
santiago pues vio que las
manifestaciones del miércoles de
sirvieron para sentar en la mesa a
gobierno empresarios y sindicatos
finalmente acordaron un alza del salario
mínimo mensual cercana al 28% es decir
el ingreso que hoy es de 17 mil pesos
argentinos o 10 218 dólares ahora será
de 21.600 pesos es decir 60 dólares más
el incremento será gradual comienza este
mes con un 12% y sigue en diciembre con
un 10 por ciento adicional
ya en marzo de 2021 subirá otro 6% para
completar ese 28% hablemos ahora de
españa y en este país subirán el iva a
las bebidas azucaradas sí señor el
aumento que será del 10 al 21 por ciento
estará dentro del plan de presupuesto de
2021 que fue presentado este jueves el
gobierno español dice que con esto
logrará hábitos más saludables entre sus
ciudadanos pero este no es el único
cambio fiscal en este país santiago el
próximo año entrarán en vigor los nuevos
impuestos digital y financiero también
un gravamen a los envases de plástico de
un solo uso con todas estas medidas del
país ibérico espera recaudar más de 8
mil millones de dólares el próximo año
una medida cada vez más común entre los
países de la unión europea hablemos
ahora de eeuu que tendrá 8 millones más
de pobres por cuenta de la pandemia que
nos puede esperar entonces en américa
latina' sí señores es lo que dice por lo
menos un estudio de la universidad de
columbia que agrega que las comunidades
más afectadas son las minorías negra
e hispana el informe elaborado por el
centro de pobreza y políticas sociales
dice que antes de la pandemia la tasa de
pobreza era cercana al 15% y ahora se
acerca al 18% esto significa que el
número de personas que viven en esta
condición pasó de 47 millones en mayo
santiago a 55 millones en septiembre y
es que una de las grandes consecuencias
que ha tenido la pandemia es que muchos
perdieron su trabajo en la última semana
volvieron a subir las peticiones de
subsidios por desempleo hablemos ahora
de los indicadores como el spa las
bolsas en la jornada de hoy y bueno pues
justamente este dato de empleo sumado a
la incertidumbre sobre un plan de
estímulos asustaron por tercera jornada
consecutiva a los inversionistas y wall
street cerró en rojo las bolsas europeas
se hundieron por el regreso de las
restricciones de movilidad y en américa
latina' un segundo día positivo para
argentina los otros índices cerraron
planos para el cierre de cifra el día
bueno sabía usted de santiago que hoy es
el aniversario número 75 del día mundial
de la alimentación nos habla bueno las
cifras son
1200 millones de puestos de trabajo que
genera este sistema alimentario en el
mundo en la mala noticia es que el 35
por ciento está en riesgo por la
pandemia día para reflexionar muchas
gracias a daniela es todo en la economía
quién france24 siga con nosotros
i